thanks for coming back on the program
always nice to have you here
speaking about me it occurs to me uh you
gave me my last emmy that's right i was
that was very cool yeah well i was had
to with your name was on the end i know
but
you could have read somebody else's
that's true no that was a nice you know
it's funny you don't really get uh it's
nice to be able to
be a presenter at an award show uh as
like the emmys because you read the name
and you came up you won and you and it
was really i felt like i was giving you
a great gift
when really i had nothing to do with it
but it was still a gesture
it's funny i uh i once gave one to
christine baranski
i had gone to juilliard with her you
know before the punic wars together
right and uh
and i presented her first emmy tour and
so there was just kind of nice
full circle quality too yeah i never got
it like a thank you note or anything
was there wow i tried to do that now
because i felt like crap about it
yeah you're all torn up about you know
what actually you know it's funny this
made me uh realize something the first
time
that i met you was uh a few years before
i even started doing this show this must
be about 14 years ago when i was working
on the simpsons and
we were working on a sideshow bob
episode
and you came in um i don't even remem
it's so long ago i don't even remember
but this was uh it was a great sideshow
bob
parody i think of bob roberts sideshow
that was the what we are we're it's the
parody of the great uh scorsese remake
and i'm blanking on everything right now
cape fear that was the and but you came
in and we had you know
written what we thought was a funny and
then you just brought this this
character to life it was so can we hear
a little sideshow bob
sure
just for me uh oh here's my mic okay
this is easier
hello bot
i just like it it brings me back
he's also it's one of the hammiest
characters ever written
you could tell that you were just having
so much fun doing you devoted
ham himself right you know i mean i'm ha
ham in the part but
uh he himself is a ham yes it's ham on
him now
i want to ask you uh about thanksgiving
thanksgiving right around the corner is
this a
warm memories for you thanksgiving in my
house was always fight night
you know well you know yeah after a year
of holding all the hostility in
you sit down to celebrate with the
family it's the only time you get them
all in the same room you know
and a couple of glasses of wine and uh
and it's magical and grandma cuts open
you know she's just grandma
yeah great great grandma's the one in
your house it was always my fault
that's my grandmother was the titular
head of the home uh uh in my
adolescence and uh she was a feisty one
she was a tough one
and so we had a lot of fights there was
a time that uh
i actually threw her boyfriend out uh of
the house
you threw grandma's boyfriend
it gets to get stranger his name was
captain bob
it was really captain bond we called him
captain bob was he a captain or was it
just well i don't know if he was a
captain he had
some men just wear a captain's hat they
just get different from people he did
run boats
he was a skipper on some boats and he
liked to be called captain bob
but um i was sitting down at dinner with
my sister
and my sister's boyfriend at the time
was a young man named danny ying who was
a
half seminal half chinese this was not
very popular in bob's mind right and so
he looked over at danny and said
exactly what color are you anyway oh my
god
well he was kind of a bigot and he was
he was in pain
yeah so i i stood up at that point i
said
okay bob that's it you gotta go so i
wish you had said you're going overboard
bob
so i picked them up by the back of the
pants and i threw them out in the house
that's oh i hope you cause if you just
put one hand they tip over but you got
to use both yeah
wow threw him out in the front yard
incredible climbed into his car and
drove away and my grandmother about an
hour later said
i want you to drive me to bob no you sit
in that room you stay there
we had a really interesting life
i think norman rockwell painted this
once bob's going out the window your
grandmother's punching you
yeah that's a wonderful scene now i
understand
uh you know you you have you're still
doing a lot of work but you have more
time on your hands now that you've
finished
frasier which is a lot of work doing one
of those programs
what are you doing with you you're
treating yourself to to some
i'm trying to take care of myself a
little bit better i'm working out once
in a while and i'm doing i've been doing
some uh
i'm spending more time with the kids
spending more time with my wife i've
been on vacation
a bit more often and i've been doing
some grooming grooming which is uh
it's usually induced by my wife um what
kind
we were in mexico a while ago and there
were a lot of really handsome young men
down there
and uh i having formerly been a handsome
young man
now a sort of aging once handsome young
man
i'm rather hairy and
[Music]
my wife said i'm glad we could talk
about this
my wife said why don't you get your back
waxed
because you've got a nice back and you
know you look you know good like all
these other
young strapping lads out here and uh so
we went down to the little salon and uh
this lovely uh as esthetician
from mexico
took i think delight
in in removing the hair from my back now
i don't even know how they do that i
know nothing about it it's pretty
barbaric actually
they roll they have a hot what looks
like a paint roller but it also looks
like it's honey
and it's like melted hot honey but you
realize that it's actually epoxy or
something
right and uh they rub that on your back
right right and then they put something
on it i don't know what it is
exactly it's some kind of cloth it's
like fiberglass and a surfboard
and uh are you sure you weren't at a
surf shop well i might have been
yeah and uh then she pats it for a
minute there and then
rips it off so while my wife and this
lovely esthetician were laughing
i was screaming and biting the pillow
like
you know the big girl that i am now what
are they what are they
do what happens to this thing when
they're done you get to keep it it's
like oh they throw that out
i didn't want to look that could be a
mat in an f1 ford truck
you could sell that on ebay you know hey
welcome to our home that's kelsey
grammer's back oh
thank you it's probably a square yard on
my back so yeah you could probably you
know upholster a chair in it or
something
well celebrity stuff goes you should
next time save that it's a fabulous
save that um it was very painful but it
did look good
yeah oh yeah so i started to understand
that you know
there's some some benefit in the pain of
of uh good grooming
so your back right now is just
completely right now my back is uh
it's sort of semi-hairy right now
because i
i've never ended interview that way i
know all right that's gonna be my new
question at the end of every area
because uh it's and that's been really
interesting laser doesn't that just set
fire to the hair on your back pretty
much
well i'm sorry i'm just picturing the
truth i'm just picturing you with this
hairy back and they fire a bond laser at
you when a
forest fire goes like that nine miles
away a ranger's like oh my god get the
trucks
it's pretty much like that wow uh
i want to mention this a christmas carol
uh which uh which you shot in
budapest beautiful location fantastic
city uh that's gonna air
this sunday at nine on uh on nbc yeah
so hey it's always great having you here
graham terrific well sorry adoption
you're coming to take a break